In this recitation, we'll
discuss operating room
scheduling.
That is, how hospitals can
be made to run smoothly.
In particular, we'll discuss how
an operating room manager can
use integer optimization to
make sure the hospital runs
smoothly.
So hospitals have a limited
number of operating rooms,
or ORs.
And operating room managers
must determine a weekly schedule
assigning ORs to different
departments in the hospital.
If you look on the
right, you'll see
a picture of an operating room.
You can see immediately how much
specialized and fancy equipment
there is.
And you have to remember that
for any surgery, staffing
the OR doesn't just involve
the surgeon performing
the surgery, but also other
doctors, nurses, residents,
and fellows.
There's usually an
entire surgery team.
So due to the specialized
equipment in an OR,
as well as the
specialized staff members,
it's been estimated that
staffing an operating room
costs over $100 a minute.
Therefore, for a hospital
to run on a budget,
it's very critical for
the operating room manager
to create a good schedule.
However, this isn't
without difficulties.
Creating an acceptable schedule
is a highly political process
within the hospital.
Surgeons are frequently paid on
a fee-for-service basis, which
means they get paid for
every surgery they perform.
That means that when you
change their allocated
number of operating
room hours, it directly
affects their income.
Therefore, the operating room
managers' proposed schedule
must strike a delicate
balance between all
the surgical departments
in the hospital.
However, there are
many logistical issues
for the operating room
manager to consider
when designing the schedule.
Operating rooms are staffed
in eight hour blocks.
Each department sets
their own target number
of allocation hours,
which may not be integer.
In addition,
departments may have
daily and weekly requirements.
For example, gynecology might
need at least one OR per day.
Ophthalmology might need
at least two ORs per week.
And for example,
the oral surgeon
might only be present on
Tuesdays and Thursdays.
The operating room manager
needs to take into account
all of these
logistical issues when
designing a feasible schedule.
In this recitation, we'll
consider a case study
of Mount Sinai
Hospital in Toronto.
There are 10 operating
rooms at Mount Sinai, which
are staffed from
Monday through Friday.
So 10 ORs times 5 days
times 8 hours per day,
means that they have 400
hours to assign between five
different surgical departments.
The departments
they are assigning
are ophthalmology, gynecology,
oral surgery, otolaryngology,
and general surgery.
Each of these
departments has come up
with a weekly number of
target allocation hours.
For example, ophthalmology
requests 39.4 hours
of operating room time,
and otolaryngology requests
26.3 hours of
operating room time.
Now, it's very clear that just
by looking at these numbers
they are not integer, and
they are certainly not
multiples of eight hours.
This means that it's impossible
for the operating room manager
to give any department exactly
their weekly number of target
allocation hours.
However, the
operating room manager
would like to try to give as
many hours to each department
as possible up to their
target allocation number.
We'll see how to solve this
with integer optimization.
Let's consider the rest
of the problem data.
For example, we need to consider
the number of surgery teams
from each department that
is available each day.
We also need to consider the
maximum number of operating
rooms required by each
department each day.
Frequently, these
numbers are the same.
For example, ophthalmology
requires at most two operating
rooms every day.
And we see that they
have two surgery
teams available every day.
However, let's look at
the case of oral surgery.
They require at most one
operating room every day.
However, the oral
surgeon is only
present on Tuesdays
and Thursdays.
Additionally, each department
has weekly requirements
on the number of
operating rooms they need.
For example, gynecology needs
to have at least 12 operating
rooms in a given
week and at most 18.
The traditional
way of doing this
was not by using
integer optimization.
Before integer optimization
was implemented
at Mount Sinai in 1999,
the operating room manager
used graph paper
and a large eraser
to try to assign the
operating room blocks.
Any changes that
were necessary were
incorporated by trial and error.
The operating room
manager made a draft,
and this schedule was circulated
to all of the surgical groups.
However, incorporating
feedback from one department
usually meant altering another
group's schedule leading
to many iterations
of this process.
In the next video, we'll
design an integer optimization
formulation for this problem.